TO SEE HIM GET ON A ROLL.
HE'S 2-0 WITH SAVED AND
SCORE.
YOU CAN SEE THAT ON HIS FOREHANR
THIS SITUATION.E TO KNOCK IT TH.
MacKINNON PUTS THETED TO PLAY I.
>> CONNOR IS BACK INN SCHEIFELE.
THE CON REWARDED BY
GOING TO THE TOUGH PARTTH A
POKEAWAY BY SCHEIFELE.
THEY HAVE NUMBERS THREE-ON-ONE,
C
PLAY AND HE REALLY DID NOTHING
ON THAT PLAY.
>> EHLERS STUCK THAT SAVED AND.
CREASE, ABLE TO BASH IT INSIDE
JUST UNCONTROLLABLE IN FRONT. S,
REBOUND, LANDESKOG SHOOTS --
EVERYTHING IS EQUAL DANGEROUS.I.
THEY LOST THE FIRST GAME AND WON
EHLELE.
>> A LOT OF TIME LEFT IN THEIT
GAME.
STEERS IT UP.
SHOT S IT GOING.
>> MacKINNON SHOOTS AND
SCORES!
HORN HRN BUDDIES SCORES!
[ HORN ]
>> GABE LANDESKOG WITH THE HAT
CC A POWER PLAY GOAL!
EJ SETS OPPORTUNITY.